la función f x es graficada cuál es su
dominio viendo la manera en la que esta
gráfica da aquí podemos asumir que esta
muestra la definición completa de la
función f x por ejemplo
si decimos aquí es igual fx cuando x es
igual a menos 9 vemos que si vamos por
aquí arriba no vemos su gráfica aquí no
está definida para x igual a menos 9 o x
igual a menos 8 y medio o x igual a
menos 8 no está definida para ninguno de
estos valores empieza a definirse cuando
x es igual a menos 6 en x igual a menos
efe es igual a 5 pero continúa estando
definida fx está definida para x en todo
el intervalo desde menos 6 hasta el 7
positivo cuando x es igual a 7 f x es
igual a 5 puedes tomar cualquier valor
de x entre menos 6 incluyendo el menos 6
y 7 positivo incluyendo el 7 positivo y
solo tienes que moverte hacia arriba de
este número desde donde estés para saber
cuál es el valor de la función en este
punto
entonces el dominio de esta de esta
función definida bueno
fx está definida para toda x que sea
igual o mayor a menos 6 o podemos decir
que menos 6 es igual o menor que x que
es menor o igual a 7 si x satisface esta
condición la función está definida por
lo que éste es su dominio así que
verifiquemos nuestra respuesta
hagamos unos cuantos más de estos
la función fx esta gráfica da cuál es su
dominio tenemos un argumento similar
esta función no está definida para
valores de x menos 9 menos 8 hasta el -1
en menos uno empieza a definirse
efe de menos uno es menos 5
así que la función está definida cuando
menos 1 es menor o igual a equis está
definida desde allí hasta x igual a 7
incluyendo x igual a 7 entonces esto de
aquí es menos 1 menor o igual a x x
menor o igual a 7 la función está
definida para cualquier x que satisfaga
esta doble desigualdad de aquí
hagamos más ejemplos
la función fx es gráfica da cuál es su
rango ahora no estamos pensando en los
valores de x en los que está definida la
función estamos pensando en el conjunto
de valores de y lo que es donde donde
caen todos los valores de y vamos a ver
el menor valor posible de iu o el menor
valor posible de fx que podemos obtener
aquí parece ser que 0 la función nunca
va más abajo de cero entonces fx es 0
que es menor o igual que fx de hecho si
llega a ser igual a 0 justo aquí donde
fx valuada en menos 4 es 0 y el valor
más grande de y el valor más grande que
fx se obtiene en esta definición de
función es 8
efe de 7 s 8 y nunca se vuelve más
grande que 8 pero si es igual a 8 justo
aquí cuando x es igual a 7
entonces 0 es menos o igual a fx la que
es menor o igual a 8 por lo que ese es
su rango hagamos uno más esto es algo
divertido
la función de fx es graficada cuál es su
dominio nuevamente esta función está
definida cuando menos 2 menos 2 es menor
o igual a equis que es menor o igual a 5
si me das una equis en cualquier lugar
entre menos 2 y 5 puedo ver esta gráfica
para ver cómo está definida esta función
efe de menos 2 es menos 4 efe de menos 1
es menos 3 y así sucesivamente puedo
escoger valores entre estos enteros así
que menos 2 es menor o igual a x que es
menor o igual a 5